Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. This is a moment to seize. The kaleidoscope has been shaken. The pieces are in flux. Soon they will settle again. Before they do, let us reorder this world around us. That was Tony Blair on the 2nd of October 2001,
感谢收听《历史其余部分》。若想收听每周独家加更节目、免广告收听、提前解锁系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。这是一个需要把握的时刻。万花筒已被摇动。碎片正在变动。很快它们就会重新安定下来。在此之前，让我们重新整理我们周围的这个世界。这是托尼·布莱尔在2001年10月2日发表的讲话，
five days before the American and British invasion of Afghanistan. And now we all know how that story ended up. So, Tom, we thought we would devote this week's podcast to a survey of Afghan history, didn't we? Explain some of the background to the events that we've been seeing in the last few days and to ask some of these sort of big questions about can empires ever intervene in Afghanistan? Is it an inherently lawless and violent place or is that just a series of kind of cliches? And also this episode will serve as an introduction to a much more focused episode, which will follow tomorrow with Willie Dalrymple, looking specifically at the episode that people often kind of compare to what's going on today, which is the first Afghan war, absolutely calamitous disaster in the history of British
即美国和英国入侵阿富汗前五天。现在我们都知道这个故事是如何结局的。所以，汤姆，我们觉得可以将本周的播客献给对阿富汗历史的概览，对吧？解释一下我们这几天所见事件的一些背景，并提出一些诸如帝国是否能干涉阿富汗这样的大问题？这里是一个天生无法无天且充满暴力的地方，还是说这只是一系列的老生常谈？此外，这一期节目将作为明天与威廉·达尔林普尔（William Dalrymple）合作的一期更聚焦节目的引子，我们将专门探讨人们经常拿来与今天发生的事情作比较的那段历史——第一次阿富汗战争，这是英国帝国主义史上绝对是一场灾难性的浩劫。
imperialism. But yes, but I think, I do think that the talk of Afghanistan as a graveyard of empires, of which obviously, for obvious reasons, there's a great deal at the moment, occludes the way in which Afghanistan has also been a great womb of empires. which imperial powers kind of gestate within Afghanistan. And then they kind of come out down the Khyber Pass, invade northern India, settle there, become kind of enervated and soft. And then the cycle repeats. I mean, that's an equally kind of resonant pattern that you can trace through history. Yeah, it is, isn't it? And also when people say, oh, they talk about the sort of medieval barbarism of the Taliban and so on. I mean, actually, the irony is that in medieval period, Afghanistan was actually a very sophisticated and civilized place. And indeed an ancient history as well. So let's put it into a bit of context. And actually, I know we both agree about this. The single most important thing is to get a sense of geography because geography comes before history famously yes uh and so actually as we're sitting here i've got a map right in front of me and crucially it doesn't
不过，是的，但我认为，我确实认为，将阿富汗称为“帝国的坟墓”的这种说法——显然，由于显而易见的原因，目前这种说法非常多——掩盖了阿富汗同样作为“帝国温床”的方式。即帝国的力量在阿富汗境内孕育。然后它们顺着开伯尔山口出来，入侵印度北部，在那里定居，变得衰弱和软弱。然后这个周期重复。我的意思是，这是一个同样具有共鸣的模式，你可以从历史中追溯到它。是的，确实如此，对吧？而且，当人们说，哦，他们谈到塔利班的某种中世纪野蛮行径等等时。我的意思是，实际上，具有讽刺意味的是，在中世纪时期，阿富汗实际上是一个非常老练和文明的地方。古代历史也是如此。所以让我们把它放在一定的语境中。事实上，我知道我们对此都有共识。最重要的一件事情就是把握地理概念，因为众所周知，地理决定历史，是的，嗯，所以实际上，当我们坐在这里时，我面前就有一张地图，至关重要的是，它不仅仅
just show the cities it shows the mountains because afghanistan is quite a kind of odd country uh i mean it's not it it's it's not i think a kind of natural nation state in the way, say, that England might be. Denmark. Denmark. You can trace the contour. So Afghanistan has a massive range of mountains running right the way through the middle of it. And the key cities kind of basically exist in relationship to that. So the northern kind of flatlands, the north of these mountain range in very ancient times was known as Bactria. And the southern range, the kind of deserts that you have there were known as Arakozia. So you've got Herat in the far west, you've got Kandahar in the far south,
显示城市，它还显示山脉，因为阿富汗是一个非常奇怪的国家，嗯，我的意思是，它不是，它不是，我认为它不是那种像英国那样自然存在的民族国家。丹麦。丹麦。你可以勾勒出它的轮廓。因此阿富汗有一条巨大的山脉一直贯穿其中央。主要的城市基本上都是围绕着它而存在的。因此，北部的平原，也就是这个山脉以北的地方，在远古时期被称为巴克特里亚。南部的山脉，也就是那里的沙漠，被称为阿拉科西亚。所以你有最西边的赫拉特，最南边的坎大哈，
and you've got Kabul in a kind of a valley which links to what is now Pakistan. But you have these massive mountains in the middle and that is really the kind of the key factor, I think, that you have to bear in mind. I mean, wouldn't you agree? I think absolutely geography is destiny. And actually the geography because it's because of that geography that you have the ethnic mix so the ethnic mix is a massive part yeah of the um of the story modern afghanistan
还有喀布尔，它位于一个连接到现在巴基斯坦的山谷里。但中间有这些巨大的山脉，我认为这确实是你必须记住的关键因素。我的意思是，你不同意吗？我认为地理绝对就是命运。事实上，正因为这种地理环境，你才有了种族融合，所以种族融合是这个故事的非常大的一部分，现代阿富汗
certainly so pashtuns what are they about 40 and then you've got tajiks hazaras uzbeks and other smaller groups of people so in other words it's not one homogenous kind of community of Afghans. It is competing people who speak different languages. And often, you know, their antagonists are each other rather than outsiders necessarily. And that reflects the fact that it's a crossroads and strategically absolutely key coming from all kinds of directions. So India, we've mentioned, and it's kind of very obvious at the moment, but also there are trade links to China, to the Stans, to the north, and I think crucially to Iran. So I think Persia is absolutely massive, massive influence. And if Ali Ansari was here, who did that kind of wonderful podcast for us
当然是这样，普什图人占百分之四十左右？然后是塔吉克人、哈扎拉人、乌兹别克人和其他较小的族群。换句话说，它不是一个单一同质的阿富汗人社群。它是讲不同语言的相互竞争的人群。而且通常情况下，你知道，他们的对手往往彼此交恶，而不一定是对外人。这反映了一个事实，即它是一个十字路口，从各个方向来看，战略地位都绝对至关重要。所以我们提到了印度，这在目前看来非常明显，但也有通往中国、北方的“斯坦”地区，以及我认为至关重要的伊朗的贸易路线。所以我觉得波斯的影响绝对是巨大、巨大的。如果阿里·安萨里（Ali Ansari）在这里——他曾为我们做过那个精彩的播客，
on the ways that Persia has influenced history, I would have no doubt in saying that Persia is probably the kind of decisive influence on the way that what is now Afghanistan has evolved. And really, what is now Afghanistan first emerges into history with the great Persian Empire. So that's the empire of Cyrus the Great. Cyrus the Great, Darius the Great emerges in the 6th century BC, endures until Alexander conquers it.
关于波斯如何影响历史的播客——我毫无疑问地会说，波斯可能是对现在阿富汗演变方式具有决定性影响的力量。事实上，现在所谓的阿富汗最初是随着伟大的波斯帝国进入历史视野的。这就是居鲁士大帝的帝国。居鲁士大帝、大流士大帝在公元前6世纪崛起，一直持续到亚历山大征服它。
And Bactria, as I mentioned, is the kind of the northern lands that lie above the kind of central mountain range in Afghanistan, and then beyond that, Sogdiana into what's now Uzbekistan. Those are satrapies or provinces of the great Persian king. And from the point of view of what happens when the Persian Empire falls, what's interesting about it is that it's a place where greeks get exiled so miletus the great city on the aegean um on what what's now turkey the milesians rebel against the persians and um city gets destroyed and the milesians get exiled to sogdiana so north of of bactria but other greeks get exiled into bactria into afghanistan it's what's now afghanistan so that's the sort of Siberia then. It's the sort of Persia's Siberia. You get sent there if they're putting you out of harm's way
而巴克特里亚，正如我所提到的，是位于阿富汗中部山脉上方的北部土地，再往外是索格狄亚那，延伸到现在的乌兹别克斯坦。这些是伟大波斯国王的总督辖区或省份。从波斯帝国灭亡时发生的事情来看，关于它有趣的是，这是一个流放希腊人的地方——米利都，爱琴海上的伟大城市，位于现在的土耳其，米利都人反叛波斯人，嗯，城市被毁，米利都人被流放到索格狄亚那，也就是巴克特里亚以北；但其他希腊人被流放到巴克特里亚，也就是阿富汗，即现在的阿富汗境内。所以那有点像那里的西伯利亚。它有点像波斯的西伯利亚。如果你被排除在危险之外，你就会被送到那里
as a sort of punishment. Yeah, absolutely. And it means that, although, I mean, they become kind of loyal subjects of the Persian king. And the Bactrians, you know, people talk about how Afghanistan is a land that is the graveyard of empires. It isn't the graveyard of Persian imperialism.
作为一种惩罚。是的，绝对是。这意味着，尽管——我的意思是，他们成为了波斯国王的忠实臣民。而巴克特里亚人，你知道，人们谈论阿富汗是一片帝国的坟墓的土地。它并不是波斯帝国主义的坟墓。
I mean, it remains a part of the Persian Empire for two centuries, basically. Which is why when Alexander turns up, he takes for granted that now that he is the great king, he's conquered the Persian Empire. These lands belong to him. Well, so this is an amazing story, isn't it? So Alexander has conquered Egypt, the Levant, the Persian heartland, and the Persian king Darius has been killed. And the guy who killed him, Bessus, his base is in Bactria. And he's shot off to Bactria and says, I'm the great king now.
我的意思是，它基本上在两个世纪里一直是波斯帝国的一部分。这就是为什么当亚历山大出现时，他认为理所当然的是，既然他已经是伟大的国王，他已经征服了波斯帝国，那么这些土地就属于他。嗯，所以这是一个惊人的故事，不是吗？所以亚历山大已经征服了埃及、黎凡特、波斯心脏地带，波斯国王大流士也被杀了。而杀死他的人贝苏斯，他的大本营就在巴克特里亚。他逃到了巴克特里亚并说，我现在是伟大的国王了。
And he goes off to his heartland, sort of over the Afghan mountains. And Alexander does what most normal people would say. I've finished now i'm the great king i should go and enjoy myself in the palace but alexander follows him doesn't he goes all the way over the mountains past carpool um this crazy expedition and captures besters and yeah which which which in complete contravention to everything that you read in the newspapers is a roaring success right i mean it takes him a very long time but he wins yes he does he does and also he he um with the the modesty for which he's famed he founds an enormous number of cities all named um alexandria after himself some of which are you know famous cities to this day so
他前往他的腹地，也就是翻越阿富汗的山脉。而亚历山大做了大多数正常人会说的话。我已经完成了，我现在是伟大的国王了，我应该去宫殿里享受生活，但亚历山大追赶他，不是吗？他一路翻山越岭，经过喀布尔，嗯，这是一次疯狂的远征，并俘获了贝苏斯，这与你在报纸上读到的一切完全背道而驰，是一次巨大的成功，对吧？我的意思是这花了很长时间，但他赢了，是的，他赢了，他确实赢了，而且他——带着他闻名遐迩的谦逊，他建立了一大批城市，都以他自己的名字命名为亚历山大，其中一些城市至今仍是著名的城市，所以
um kandahar is um is one of the cities that he founded. Is that Alexandria in Arakozia? Yeah, but Kandahar, obviously, is a Kanda. You can see the kind of the derivation. Ghazni, which becomes a crucial, a really, really important city in the early years of the Muslim conquest. That's Alexandria in Opiana. Even beyond Afghanistan. So further north, you've got Alexandria, Eskete, Alexandria the furthest, which is kind of the outer limits of Greek civilization.
嗯，坎大哈就是他建立的城市之一。那是阿拉科西亚的亚历山大吗？是的，但是坎大哈，显然，是一个坎大。你可以看到这种演变。加兹尼，在穆斯林征服的早期成为一个关键的、非常非常重要的城市。那是奥皮安娜的亚历山大。甚至超越了阿富汗。所以更往北，你有亚历山大·埃斯科特，最远处的亚历山大，它有点像是希腊文明的最外围界限。
And then you have this city, Alexandria on the Oxus, which after Alexander has died and his general Seleucus takes over the kind of the vast bulk of the Persian Empire, there's this kind of renegade satrap who basically casts off his loyalty to the distant Seleucid Empire and establishes this kingdom, this Bactrian Greek kingdom that survives for centuries. And actually it's independent long after Greece and the Macedonian realms have been conquered by the Romans. This is, yes, it's like something from a video game, isn't it? It's like something from a strategy game. Well, I think it's like a science fiction story. It's kind of like those science fiction stories where there are earth colonists on Mars and then the Earth blows up and you've only got this colony left. So there's this amazing city that they found, I think, in the 70s that were being excavated by French archaeologists when the Soviets invaded in 1979 and they had to stop.
然后你有了这座城市——奥克苏斯的亚历山大，在亚历山大去世后，他的将军塞琉古接管了波斯帝国的绝大部分，这里有一个叛逆的总督，他基本上抛弃了对遥远的塞琉古帝国的忠诚，建立了这个王国，这个巴克特里亚希腊王国，存续了几个世纪。事实上，在希腊和马其顿王权被罗马人征服很久之后，它依然保持着独立。这，是的，这就像电子游戏里的东西，不是吗？这就像战略游戏里的东西。嗯，我觉得这就像一个科幻故事。这有点像那种科幻故事，火星上有地球殖民者，然后地球炸了，你只剩下这个殖民地了。所以这是一座令人惊叹的城市，我想是他们在70年代发现的，当时法国考古学家正在发掘，1979年苏联入侵，他们不得不停止。
And then they went back in the 90s and again they had to stop. But it's this extraordinary Greek city. So that's in the, looking at the map, it's the kind of the northeast region of what is now Afghanistan in the shadow of the mountains. And it's this great Greek city with theaters and with temples. It's kind of an amazing image of Kibale, who fans of the World Cup of Gods will remember. The worst wedding of all time. So she's portrayed. Is it called Ikanum?
然后在90年代他们又回去了，结果又不得不停止。但这是一座非凡的希腊城市。所以，看看地图，那是现在阿富汗的东北部地区，在群山的阴影下。这是一座伟大的希腊城市，有剧院和神庙。这有点像是库贝勒（Kibale）的惊人形象，众神世界杯的粉丝们会记得。史上最糟糕的婚礼。所以她被描绘成。这叫伊卡努姆（Ikanum）吗？
That's right, yes. Which means Lady Moon in Uzbek, apparently. Right. And they found bilingual coins, I read. Amazing. So half in one side is in Greek and the Pakistan, but includes a lot of what is currently Afghanistan. And in complex ways that I would not want to tease out because I'm really not qualified to do it. Greek cultural artistic influences inform the development of buddhist art yeah which is starting to come up from north india into what is now afghanistan and there's all this kind of that the smart that the smile of apollo becomes the smile of the buddha that's absolutely fascinating
没错，是的。显然在乌兹别克语中意思是月亮夫人。对。我读到他们还发现了双语硬币。太神奇了。所以一面的一半是用希腊语和巴基斯坦语写的，但包含了目前阿富汗的大部分领土。并以我不想梳理的复杂方式，因为我真的没有资格这样做。希腊的文化艺术影响了佛教艺术的发展，是的，佛教艺术开始从印度北部进入现在的阿富汗，所有这些——阿波罗的微笑变成了佛陀的微笑，这绝对令人着迷。
i think yeah it is fascinating and it's very complicated and very controversial so i so the listeners can't see this but i can see that you're nervous about it which tantalizes me well it's it's it's much debated and i i wouldn't want to pretend that i but at this point tom i mean there's a couple of things that occur to me one is that um alexander did conquer afghanistan so you can't not conquer as the persians are done as the persians are done and the second thing is that it's not it's clearly not ludicrously violent and lawless, because as you say, the Greco-Bactrian kingdom lasts for centuries. Yes, and it gets destroyed by nomadic raiders coming in from the north, which is another kind of perpetual theme,
我想是的，是的，这很迷人，而且非常复杂，也非常有争议，所以——所以听众看不到这一点，但我能看出你对此感到紧张，这让我很着迷。嗯，这——这争论很多，我不想假装我——但此时此刻，汤姆，我的脑海里浮现出几件事：一是，嗯，亚历山大确实征服了阿富汗，所以你不能不征服，就像波斯人做过的那样，正如波斯人所做的那样；第二件事是，它不是——它显然不是荒谬地暴力和无法无天，因为正如你所说，希腊-巴克特里亚王国持续了几个世纪。是的，它被从北方入侵的游牧袭击者摧毁了，这也是另一个永恒的主题，
that Afghanistan on its northern flank is open to nomadic armies. And that's what wipes out um i can um yeah but also the idea that afghanistan is that you see very much in the newspapers now afghanistan is kind of presented as the antithesis of of kind of western values and so on but obviously there's a point in ancient history it was a a haven of western art and religion and people stripping off in the gymnasiums and doing what they do. And into the early Middle Ages as well. So it becomes one of the great centres of Buddhism. And the famous place is Bamiyan with the two extraordinary sculptures there that go up, I think, in 550 AD, 610.
即阿富汗的北翼向游牧军队开放。这就是消灭了伊卡努姆的原因。是的，但阿富汗的理念也是——你在现在的报纸上经常看到阿富汗被描绘成西方价值观等的对立面，但显然在古代历史上的某个时期，它是西方艺术和宗教的避难所，人们在体育馆里脱衣服做他们做的事。一直延续到中世纪早期。所以它成为佛教的伟大中心之一。著名的地点是巴米扬，那里有两座非凡的雕塑，我想它们建于公元550年、610年。
And you get records of Chinese travellers, you know, Buddhists who are coming. And they report that, you know, there are multitudes of monasteries there in Bamiyan that Buddhism has become, I think, kind of arrives there, 1st, 2nd centuries AD. And by the 6th, by the seventh centuries, it's become this great center for Buddhist civilization. So absolutely, it's a meeting place as well as a place where people kind of clash and fight. Because the Silk Road is basically skirting the northern flank
你还会得到中国旅行者的记录，你知道，前来朝圣的佛教徒。他们报告说，你知道，巴米扬有众多的寺庙，佛教已经——我想它是在公元1到2世纪左右到达那里的。到了公元6世纪、7世纪，它已经成为佛教文明的一个伟大中心。所以当然，它既是一个交汇点，也是人们发生冲突和战斗的地方。因为丝绸之路基本上沿着北部边缘延伸
of Afghanistan, isn't it? So the Bukhara, Tashkent, Kiva, Samarkand. I mean, they're to the north, but obviously their influence must come south and into the... But Bamiyan is in the mountains. And I think it's on a road that enables the kind of, you know, there's a mountain route that takes you to China as well. So that's its significance. And that's why people from China,dhists from china come and and meet there but then of course um it's not good news for buddhism in the long run because um with the emergence of
阿富汗，不是吗？所以布哈拉、塔什干、希瓦、撒马尔罕。我的意思是，它们在北方，但显然它们的影响一定向南进入了……但巴米扬在群山之中。而且我认为它在一条能够让人们——你知道，有一条通往中国的山路。这就是它的意义所在。这就是为什么来自中国的人——来自中国的佛教徒来到那里并相遇——但当然，从长远来看，这对佛教来说不是好消息，因为随着
islam you have islamic armies turning up and actually take quite a long time for what will become afghanistan to be Islamized. So the first great Islamic kingdom has as its focus Ghazni, which is Alexandria in Opiana, this Alexandrian foundation. And this is the kind of the first great Islamic kingdom. But even even then it's it's um it's open to all kinds of invasions 1150 it gets sacked by this terrifying tajik conqueror who calls himself the world burner the world burner it's very world burner kind of game of thrones type nickname well it's so okay so it's so game of thrones he he makes the the inhabitants carry the earth of their sacked city to his capital which is a place called firoz co in the mountains of gore i'm just reading that off i have no idea
伊斯兰教的出现，你有了伊斯兰军队的出现，实际上花了好长时间才使将要成为阿富汗的地区伊斯兰化。因此，第一个伟大的伊斯兰王国的焦点是加兹尼，也就是奥皮安娜的亚历山大，这座亚历山大建城。这是第一个伟大的伊斯兰王国。但即便如此，它也经受了各种各样的入侵，1150年，它被一个可怕的塔吉克征服者洗劫，他自称为“世界焚烧者”。“世界焚烧者”，这很有“权力的游戏”式的昵称。好吧，所以——好吧，这太“权力的游戏”了，他让居民们将他们被洗劫的城市的泥土运到他的首都，一个叫做菲鲁兹库（Firoz Ko）的地方，在戈尔的山脉里——我只是从上面读到的，我不知道
where that is but it sounds great and they they carry this the soil of uh garsney all the way to firoz co in the mountains of gore um and you know what the uh the world burner does then um he covers them with the soil or something no he butchers them and he mixes their blood with the soil and he uses it as water to build victory towers wow that is yeah that's so if we're giving the impression that this is all you know that in the medieval time it's all hippies hanging out yeah it is all people It's all people painting exquisite miniatures. There's an enormous amount of slaughter going on. Yes, but as there is everywhere, to be fair.
那在哪里，但听起来很棒——他们把加兹尼的泥土一路运到戈尔山脉的菲鲁兹库，你知道“世界焚烧者”接下来做了什么吗？他用泥土把他们盖住什么的？不，他屠杀他们，把他们的血和泥土混合在一起，用它作为水来建造胜利塔。哇，那是，是的，所以如果我们给人一种印象，这都是——你知道，在中世纪，这全是嬉皮士聚在一起，是的，全是人，全都是在画精美微型画的人。这里有大量的屠杀正在发生。是的，但公平地说，到处都是这样。
I mean, it's not like there's not lots of slaughter elsewhere. But I think the sense that at any moment, terrifying hordes of invaders, kind of Dothraki type invaders, sweep down. I mean, that is, you know, you compare it to a computer game. That is the jeopardy that might strike at any minute. And of course, the famous ones are the Mongols. So when do they, what point do they pitch up? So they've conquered China, presumably, and they haven't yet gone to Europe. No, I think that Afghanistan is the first target. Oh, right.
我的意思是，这并不是说其他地方没有大量的屠杀。但我认为那种随时都可能有可怕的入侵者 horde——类似多斯拉克人的入侵者——席卷而下的感觉。我的意思是，你可以把它比作电脑游戏。那是随时可能爆发的危险。当然，最著名的就是蒙古人。那么他们什么时候，在什么时间点出现呢？所以他们大概已经征服了中国，但还没有去欧洲。不，我认为阿富汗是第一个目标。哦，对。
I think. Because of the wealth of its citizens and so on, I suppose. No, because they insult Genghis Khan's ambassadors. Oh, that's absolute folly. I think Genghis Khan sends ambassadors saying, let's be friends. People always do that with the Mongols, don't they? Don't they do that in Baghdad and places like that? They say, ah, they're inconsequential.
我想。因为它的公民的财富等等，我猜。不，因为他们侮辱了成吉思汗的使者。哦，那是绝对的愚蠢。我想成吉思汗派使者说，让我们成为朋友吧。人们对蒙古人总是那样做，不是吗？他们在巴格达和类似的地方不也这样做吗？他们说，啊，他们无足轻重。
We can just insult them with impunity. They singe the beards of the Mongol ambassadors and send them back to Genghis Khan. That's reckless. Which is not sensible. Right. It all goes horribly wrong. So you mentioned the Hazaras.
我们可以肆无忌惮地侮辱他们。他们烧掉了蒙古使者的胡子，并把他们送回成吉思汗那里。这太鲁莽了。这是不明智的。对。这一切都变得糟糕透顶。所以你提到了哈扎拉人。
So they are kind of almost certainly Mongols who are part of this kind of suite. And they're up in the mountains. And they become Shia Muslims. Yeah. And that's why the Buddhas of Bamiyan survive. Because the Shia are much more tolerant of statuary and visual representation. Yeah. If they were Sunni muslim perhaps they'd be less tolerant of the uh of the statues but there they are so that's a part a further part of the kind
所以他们几乎可以肯定是属于这个群体一部分的蒙古人。他们在山里。他们成为了什米派穆斯林。是的。这就是巴米扬大佛得以幸存的原因。因为什米派对雕像和视觉表现要宽容得多。是的。如果他们是逊尼派穆斯林，也许他们对雕像的容忍度会更低，但事实就是如此，所以这是将要成为阿富汗的融合过程的又一部分。因此，此时并没有阿富汗作为阿富汗的概念，它充其量只是别人帝国的一个省份，大体上是这样的。我不确定人们是否会从省份的角度来思考。我的意思是，这是人民，是城市，你拥有这种不断兴衰的帝国旋涡。所以你也有帖木儿。也就是苔木儿。苔木儿，瘸子帖木儿，马洛斯伟大戏剧的主角，不是吗？——“做国王并骑着凯旋穿过波斯波利斯是多么勇敢”。
of the mix of of uh of what will become afghanistan so at this point there's no sense of afghanistan as afghanistan it's merely a province of other people's empires, by and large. I'm not sure that people would even be thinking in terms of provinces. I mean, it's peoples, it's cities, and you have this kind of constant swirl of empires that rise and fall. So you also have Timur. So that's Tamerlane. Tamerlane, Timur the Lame, hero of Marlow's great play, is it not, Passing Brave to be a King and Ride in Triumph through Persepolis.
但他也凯旋骑行穿过了阿富汗的许多伟大城市。他的军队做的酷事之一就是用盾牌从山坡上滑雪。这非常令人印象深刻。这非常令人印象深刻，不是吗？它既可怕又带有讨人喜欢的孩子气。是的，完全如此。所以——所以这些种——这些源自北方的具有恐怖帝国思维的军阀的循环，最终导致了莫卧儿帝国的崛起。但在你继续讲莫卧儿帝国之前，汤姆，帖木儿——帖木儿，我没记错的话，在帖木儿统治下，赫拉特或阿富汗是一个非常成功、充满生机的地方？赫拉特尤其是这样，这是一个亚历山大时期的基础，亚历山大时期的地区，我认为，罗伯特·拜伦（Robert Byron）——伟大的作家，20世纪初的经典旅行作家，在他的书《奥克苏斯之路》中说，你知道，赫拉特太棒了，它很美丽，它是东方世界的佛罗伦萨，他们都在做天文学研究，建造可爱的叫拜楼，所有这些东西。
But he also rides in triumph through many of the great cities of Afghanistan. One of the cool things that his troops do is that they toboggan down the side of a mountain on their shields. That's very impressive. It's very impressive, isn't it? It's both fearsome and um and pleasingly childlike yes exactly so so these kind of you know these these cycles of um kind of terrifyingly imperially minded um warlords coming from the north uh culminates in uh the moguls but before
所以在那一点上，阿富汗实际上——或者说将要成为阿富汗的地方是非常文明的，对吧？我想是的，它是所有这些来到这里的各种民族和波斯的融合，所以，你知道，这些是对波斯持久影响的伟大纪念碑。而赫拉特、坎大哈，你知道，这些是——从腹地、波斯腹地向上走很容易，路上没有山脉阻挡你。因此，波斯的影响是如此强大和压倒性，以至于这些城市和纪念碑真正起到的就是这种作用。我想，虽然我从未去过它们，但我的意思是，
you go on to the moguls tom the tamil the tamerlane timur am i not right in thinking that um under the timurid rule herat or afghanistan was was a very successful buoyant place in the herat in particular which is an alexandrian foundation alexandrian area i think um that rob i mean robert byron the great writer, sort of classic early 20th century travel writer, in his book, The Road to Oxyana, he says, you know, Herat is amazing, it's beautiful, it's the Florence of the kind of eastern world and they are all sort of, you know, doing astronomy and, you know, building lovely minarets and all this sort of stuff.
去参观它们是一种持久的梦想，自从——可能不会，我不会——我不会预订假期，现在不是时候，现在不是时候，不。但是，是的——而且在某种程度上，当我想象中亚的形象时，那些就是——宏伟的清真寺、宏伟的塔楼、宏伟的纪念碑，这些就是浮现在你脑海中的东西。绝对的，我的意思是，那是将要成为阿富汗的历史中至关重要的一部分。我们一直说“将要成为阿富汗”，因为当时它还没有成为阿富汗，这正是莫卧儿帝国的原因。是的，抱歉，我把你岔开去讲莫卧儿帝国了。
So at that point, Afghanistan is actually, or what becomes afghanistan is very civilized right i i think it's yeah it's it's this fusion of of um all these various peoples who've come down and and persia so right you know these are these are great monuments to the enduring influence of persian. And Herat, Kandahar, you know, these are, it's easy to go from the heartland, the Persian heartlands up, you know, there are no mountains in the way blocking you off. And so the Persian influence is so strong and so overwhelming that that's really what these cities and monuments do. I think, although I've never been to them, I mean,
他们算是中世纪世界与早期现代世界之间的纽带，这个现代世界最终将成为不列颠印度（British India）的世界，当然也是沙皇俄国的世界。所以莫卧儿帝国的关键人物，奠基人是一个叫巴布尔（Babur）的人，他声称自己既是成吉思汗又是苔木儿的后代。他大约是欧洲亨利八世、弗朗索瓦一世、查理五世等所有16世纪早期人物的同时代人。
it's a kind of enduring dream to go and visit them ever since probably not i wouldn't i wouldn't book a holiday not the time now not the time now no um but yeah i mean and in a way when when i suppose when you you know you kind of conjure up images of uh of central asia those are the you know the the great mosques the great towers the great monuments those are what come into into your mind and absolutely i mean that's a crucial part of the history of what will become afghanistan and we keep saying what will become afghanistan because it hasn't yet become afghanistan uh and that's really why it it's it's the moguls yes sorry i took you off in the moguls.
而且他觉得——他基本上认同的不是——他没有向南看，他向北看。所以他觉得自己被放逐出了撒马尔罕，撒马尔罕的塔楼。他想把它们夺回来。他有一种复仇主义的渴望。他想收复它们。但相反，他最终征服了喀布尔。对，哇。所以他是非常——我的意思是，在西方鲜为人知，
Who are kind of the link between that medieval world and the world of the early modern that will become, in due course, the world of British India and indeed of Tsarist Russia. So the key figure of the moguls, the founder is a guy called Babur, who claims descent from both Genghis Khan and Tamburlian he's i think he's kind of contemporary of henry the eighth francis the first charles v all those kind of early 16th century guys in in europe um and he is he feels that he he basically identifies with um not with he doesn doesn't look south, he looks north.
但显然是一个极其令人印象深刻的帝国建设者。从喀布尔到德里，我的意思是，那不是一个小——你知道，那不是一个小的跨越。这是一个相当大的飞跃。是的。所以从那时起，莫卧儿帝国的中心基本上就在德里。是的。喀布尔变得边缘化。
So he feels that he's been exiled from Samarkand, the towers of Samarkand. He wants them back. And he has this kind of irredentist yearning. He wants to reclaim them. But instead, he ends up conquering Kabul. Right. And this is really where Kabul enters the the story and kabul provides easy access down into the the flatlands of the south into into the the punjab and so to pakistan basically yeah into what will become pakistan um and he conquers kabul and he praises it a place where you can go in a single day to a place where
我的意思是，它被用作避暑首都。因此，莫卧儿皇帝有时会去喀布尔以避开印度平原的酷热。但它不是重力中心。当然，这基本上就是随后引发18世纪和19世纪伟大戏剧的背景。是的，这给你提供了一种感觉，不是吗？——关于阿富汗被拉向不同方向的感觉。所以你谈到了波斯，
the snow never falls and in two hours you can also reach a place where the snow never melts. Something for all tastes. And he spends two decades basically consolidating his rule in Kabul and then he does what anyone would do after two decades of consolidating rule in Kabul. He conquers Delhi. Right, wow. So he's very, I mean, little known in the West,
但显然还有印度。我的意思是，一旦有了莫卧儿帝国，重力中心显然就向南移动到了印度。你有一种感觉，不是吗？——这正是你所说的十字路口被拉扯的时刻。有不同的文化影响力，但显然有不同的帝国势力将这视为他们开始向南扩张的重要部分。你拥有北印度正在衰落的莫卧儿帝国。
but obviously an enormously impressive empire builder. To go Kabul to Delhi is a, I mean, that's not a small, you know, that's not a small hop. It's quite a leap. Yeah. And so from that point on, the Mughals basically are centered in Delhi. Yeah. Kabul becomes peripheral.
它正在被东印度公司吞噬。是的，也被波斯吞噬。你会记得关于东印度公司的那一期节目，当时那个可怕的波斯征服者纳迪尔沙（Nadir Shah）突然冲出波斯，在1739年的卡纳尔战役中击败了莫卧儿人，占领了德里，并基本上将整个莫卧儿国库运到了波斯。这使纳迪尔沙确立了自己作为1750年代最伟大帝国的统治者的地位。
I mean, it serves as a summer capital. So on occasion, the Mughal emperors will go up to Kabul to get away from the heats of the Indian plains. But it's not the centre of gravity. And that, of course, is basically what then sets up the great dramas of the 18th and 19th century. Yeah, so that gives you a sense, doesn't it, of Afghanistan being pulled in different directions. So you've talked about Persia,
你知道，他是一个不可思议的力量。被吸收到他的帝国中的军阀之一是一个叫艾哈迈德·汗（Ahmed Khan）的人。他是来自坎大哈地区的普什图人，所以他在阿富汗中央山脉南部的区域。就像奥斯曼帝国将征服的儿童带入他们的队伍并训练他们成为近卫军一样。他是纳迪尔沙手下一名被征服对手的儿子。1747年，纳迪尔沙在波斯北部被暗杀。艾哈迈德·汗和一群普什图同伴在一起。他们抢走了光之山钻石，也就是纳迪尔沙从莫卧儿人那里夺走的那颗大钻石。
but obviously then India. I mean, presumably once you've got the Mughal Empire, then the centre of gravity has moved south towards India. And you get a sense, don't you, of the this is at that point that you made about the crossroads being pulled. And there are different cultural influences, but obviously there are different imperial powers who see this as an important part of their sort of, you know, which is starting to expand southwards. You've got the decaying empire of the Mughals in North India.
他带着这颗钻石和大量的财宝去了坎大哈。他用这些财宝。他把财宝分发给各个军阀。他确立了自己作为大佬的地位。这确实是阿富汗开始崛起的地方。我的意思是，“阿富汗”并不是阿富汗人自己使用的词，但“Afghan”是普什图人的波斯语单词。
Which is being eaten by the East India Company. Yeah, but also by Persia. And you'll remember the episode on the East India Company where this terrifying Persian conqueror, Nadir Shah, suddenly storms out of Persia, defeats the Mughals at the Great Battle of Karnal in 1739 and captures Delhi and basically carts off the entire Mughal treasury to Persia. And that enables Nadir Shah to establish himself as probably the ruler of the greatest empire of the 1750s.
所以你第一次有了一个普什图帝国或王国。“Afghan”这个词在波斯是一个古老的词。因此，萨珊帝国是公元三世纪在罗马帝国东翼崛起的伟大帝国。在早期的那些年里，早在公元三世纪，你就有铭文提到阿富汗人是那些，你知道的，
You know, he's this incredible power. And one of the kind of the warlords who gets absorbed into his empire is a guy called Ahmed Khan. And he is a Pashtun from the region of kandahar so he is in the kind of the south of the kind of the great central mountain range of of afghanistan and he rather like the ottomans kind of take uh you know conquer children into uh into their train and train them to be Janissaries. He's the son of a conquered opponent who is in the train of Nadir Shah. And in 1747, Nadir Shah is assassinated in northern Persia. And Ahmed Khan is with a kind of posse of fellow Pashtuns. And they grab the Koh-i-Noor, which is, you know, the great diamond that Nadir Shah had taken from the Mughals.
居住在后来成为坎大哈周围的人。而且，有趣的是，就像在西方，你有爱尔兰人或苏格兰人或其他任何人宣称
And he takes it and a whole load of treasure up to Kandahar. And he uses the treasure. He parcels the treasure out to all the kind of various warlords. And he establishes himself as the big cheese. And this really is where Afghanistan starts to emerge. I mean, Afghanistan is not a word that the Afghans themselves use, but Afghan is the Persian word for Pashtun.
自己是《圣经》人物的后代一样。阿富汗人也是如此。他们是谁的后代？嗯，他们声称自己是某个叫阿富那（Afghana）的人的后代，他是圣经中扫罗王的孙子，也是所罗门王手下的首席将军。
So you've got a Pashtun empire or kingdom for the first time. And the word Afghan is an ancient one in Persia. So the Sassanid Empire, which is the great empire that emerges on the eastern flank of the Roman Empire in the third century AD. In those early years, back in the third century AD, you have inscriptions referring to Afghans as the people who, you know,
是吗？我不记得这个人了。不，这完全是编造的，对吧？他是一个完全虚构的人物，用来解释为什么他们被称为阿富汗人。但你确实……扫罗不会是我选择的人，因为难道他不是……是的，他迎来了可怕的结局。是的。他不是我从圣经中选择的作为祖先的第一人选。好吧，不管怎样。
who live around what will become Kandahar. And, um, intriguingly, just as in the West, you have kind of, you know, the Irish or the Scots or whoever lay claim,
但他仍然是《圣经》里的人物，这相当有品位。因此，从16世纪、17世纪到18世纪，确实有这样的传统，即普什图人实际上是以色列人的后代。以色列失踪的支派。我不知道这一点，这非常——这太离奇了。我不认为这是塔利班真正强调的东西。不，其实，嗯，我无法想象
uh, to a descent from biblical figures. So we'll say to the Afghans. Who are they descended from? Well, they, they claim to be descended from somebody called afghana who is the grandson of the biblical king saul and who was the uh the chief general
来自以色列的支派，但——但这是一个持久的传说，所以你——你知道，这非常有趣，在伊斯兰世界，正如在早期中世纪基督教世界一样，这种对新兴民族、新兴帝国的渴望，去宣称这种古老的血统，你知道，这是连接东西方的事物。非常有趣。这连接了东西方，真的非常有趣。嗯，这对这个家伙——艾哈迈德·汗——变得很重要，他采用了“杜里·杜兰”（Dur-i-Duran，珍珠之珠）的名字，他通过将他的部落名称更改为“杜兰尼”（Durrani），从而掩盖了基本上是他的部落在接管权力这一事实。所以你知道，珍珠之珠。我也许会选择那个。珍珠男。我开始这样称呼自己。
under solomon is that i don't remember him no it's completely made up right he's a completely made up figure to explain why they're called afghans. But you do... Saul wouldn't be the person I'd choose because isn't he... Yeah, he comes to a horrible end. Yeah. He's not the first person from the Bible I'd choose to dissent from. Well, whatever.
我觉得这是一个好名字。是的，这是一个宏伟的头衔，不是吗？因此，他建立了这种杜兰尼王权，基本上，你知道，夹在波斯中间，夹在莫卧儿帝国中间，夹在俄罗斯中间。它开始承担现代阿富汗的一些特征。它实际上比现代阿富汗还要大，因为它包括了现在巴基斯坦的一大片土地。但这是一个非常
But he's still biblical, which is quite classy. And so through the 16th and 17th centuries into the 18th century, you do have these traditions that the Pashtuns are actually descended from the Israelites. The lost tribes of Israel I did not know that that's a very um that's that's bizarre I don't think something the Taliban really major on no actually no I can't
你知道，你第一次得到了一个阿富汗政体，嗯，你知道的，杜兰是相当成功的。杜兰，杜兰——也许我们已经有很多集没有提到杜兰了，我很高兴我们——我没想到我们会在这个地方提到它，但，是的，意料之外的发展让我感到惊讶。你知道他是怎么死的吗？他被狼吃掉了。不，他——没有，没有，没有。他的鼻子上有个溃疡，然后恶化了。哦，这既平庸又可怕。他的鼻子被吃掉了，溃疡了。
imagine from the tribes of Israel but uh but that was that was a kind of enduring um story and so you you you know it's it's so interesting how in the Islamic world, as in the kind of early medieval Christian world, this kind of desire for emergent peoples, emergent empires to lay claim to this kind of ancient pedigree is, you know, it's something that kind of joins East and West. Really interesting. kind of joins east and west really really interesting um and it becomes important for this guy uh ahmed khan um who takes on the name duri duran the pearl of pearls and he disguises the fact that basically his tribe is taking over by changing um the name of his tribe to durani so you know pearl of of pearls. I might choose that. Pearl guys. I start referring to myself as that.
好吧，好吧。我相信这其中有什么隐喻，但我不知道是为了什么。这就为“大博弈”做了铺垫，因为“大博弈”就要来了，不是吗？确实如此，因为发生的事情是，他的后代，他的儿子和孙子，将领地输给正在崛起地锡克帝国。是的。
I think that's a good one. Yeah, it's a magnificent title, isn't it? And so he established this kind of Durrani kingship, which basically, you know, wedged in between Persia, wedged in between the Mughal Empire, wedged in between Russia. It's starting to uh the mogul empire wedged in between russia it it's starting to take on some of the lineaments of modern afghanistan it's actually larger than than modern afghanistan so it includes a large chunk of what is now pakistan but it's a very
你还记得我们请过萨特纳姆·桑盖拉（Satnam Sanghera）来做客。我们请过。谈论帝国主义的罪恶。锡克人强大得令人难以置信。嗯，我们问过萨特纳姆，人们对锡克帝国主义有什么看法？我们知道阿富汗人对锡克帝国主义的看法，那就是他们并不赞成。对。因为锡克人割占了他们大片的领土。
you know it's it's for the first time you're getting a kind of afghan polity um and uh you know and and and durian is very successful durian durian is perhaps we haven't had a durian reference for uh many episodes i'm glad that we i wouldn't have expected this would be the place we get it in but uh yeah unexpected development surprised me and do you know how he dies um he's eaten by a wolf no he's no no no. He has an ulcer on his nose and it goes septic. Oh, that's kind of banal but also horrible. His nose gets eaten up, ulcerates.
因此杜兰的儿子和孙子非常渴望把它夺回来。但他们失败了。是的，这是背景的一部分。正如你所说，这是更大博弈的一部分，当然，这涉及到南方的波斯，北方的沙皇俄国，但现在越来越涉及我们所描述的不列颠印度。是的，当然，因为我的意思是，这就是“大博弈”，不是吗？我们的某些听众会读过彼得·霍普基尔克（Peter Hopkirk）的书。精彩的书。我记得我十几岁的时候读过它们，简直被深深迷住了。
Right, okay. I'm sure there's some metaphor there but I don't know what it's for. So this sort of cues up the great game because the great game is coming, isn't it? It does because what happens is that his descendants, his son and his grandson, they lose territory to the emergent Sikh empire. Yeah.
这些英国特工或东印度公司特工穿越这些山隘并降临到这些卡纳特（地下水渠）的故事。他们基本上就是詹姆斯·邦德式的人物。他们确实是。任何读过威廉·达尔林普尔的《国王归来》的人都会知道，这绝对是英国第一次入侵阿富汗的背景，那场战争大错特错，威廉明天会出现在节目中，是的，谈论那个。所以希望今天这一集的前半部分基本上能起到铺垫的作用，
And you remember we had Satnam Sanghera on. We did. Talking about the iniquities of imperialism. Unbelievably formidable the Sikhs are. Well, and we asked Satnam, how did people feel about Sikh imperialism? And we know how the Afghans felt about Sikh imperialism, which is namely that they weren't in favour of it. Right. Because the Sikhs nicked a vast swathe of their territory.
嗯，所以如果你还没听——请务必收听明天威廉的那期节目，因为——我希望我们已经为它提供了背景；嗯，我觉得我们现在应该休息一下，我想当我们回来时，我们应该看的不是第一次阿富汗战争——因为威廉会谈论那个——而是第二次和第三次阿富汗战争，以及阿富汗在20世纪和21世纪的历史。是的，这是一个非常黑暗但迷人的故事。
And so the son and the grandson of Duryodhana were very keen to get it back. And they failed. Yeah. So that's part of the context. And as you say, this is part of a much larger game, which involves, of course, Persia to the south, Cyrus Russia to the north, but now increasingly, what we have described as British India. Yes, of course, because I mean, this is the great game, isn't it? And some of our listeners will have read those books by Peter Hopkirk. Wonderful books. I remember reading them when I was a teenager and just being utterly captivated.
我们很快就会回来。回头见。回头见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝秀场八卦的固定栏目，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，
These stories of British agents or East India Company agents kind of crossing these mountain passes and descending on these carnates. They're basically James Bond figures. They are. And anyone who has read Willieie dalrymple's return of a king will know that this is absolutely the the kind of the the context for the first british invasion of afghanistan which goes horribly wrong and which we will willie will be on tomorrow's show yeah talking about that so i hope that this first half of today's episode has served basically to kind of set that
并告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要免广告收听、加更节目和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。似乎由于两次成功的战役、庞大军队的使用以及大量资金的消耗，所有已经取得的成果只是那个我们希望看到强大、友好和独立的国家的解体。那是自由党政府的印度事务大臣哈丁顿勋爵（Lord Hartington）
up um so do make sure if you've uh you know do make sure to tune into that episode tomorrow with willie um because uh i hope we've kind of provided the setting for it um i think we should have a break now and i think that when we we come back we should look at not the first afghan war because willie will be talking about that, but about the second and third Afghan wars, and then the history of Afghanistan in the 20th century and into the 21st. Yes, a very dark but fascinating story.
所以，务必请大家收听明天威利的那期节目，因为希望我们已经为它做好了铺垫。我想我们现在该休息一下了，等我们回来后，我们应该关注的不是第一次阿富汗战争，因为威利会谈到那个，而是第二次和第三次阿富汗战争，以及20th世纪到21世纪阿富汗的历史。是的，这是一个非常黑暗但迷人的故事。
We'll be back soon. See you then. See you then. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman, and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment
我们很快回来。到时见。到时见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《娱乐其余》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、少量娱乐圈八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐行业的帷幕，
and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. It appears that, as the result of two successful campaigns, of the employment of an enormous force and of the expenditure of large sums of money, all that has yet been accomplished has been the disintegration of the state which it was desired to see strong, friendly and independent. That was Lord Hartington, Secretary of State for India in the Liberal
并告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。似乎由于两场成功的战役、庞大兵力的使用以及巨额资金的支出，迄今所取得的全部成果，只是瓦解了那个人们希望看到它强大、友好和独立的国家。那是印度事务大臣、自由党人哈丁顿勋爵的话。
Government, writing in 1880 after the Second Afghan War of 1878 to 79. And Dominic, it has a certain kind of echo there, isn't there? So the Second Afghan War, they go in and basically it goes much better than the first one. Yes. So the great game, basically for people who don't know, is this sort of strange game of chess between Tsarist Russia, which is expanding to Central Asia, and British India. And the British in particular are paranoid that the Russians are going to use Afghanistan as a kind of launch pad to attack India. Come down through the Khyber Pass, as so many had done before. So it becomes incredibly important to them to keep Afghanistan as a kind of neutral buffer state. And they're absolutely paranoid about Russian influence.
政府，写于1880年第二次阿富汗战争（1878-79年）之后。多米尼克，那里某种程度上有一种回声，对吧？所以第二次阿富汗战争，他们打进去，基本上比第一次顺利得多。是的。所以伟大的博弈，基本上对于不了解的人来说，是沙皇俄国（正在向中亚扩张）与英属印度之间一种奇怪的国际象棋游戏。英国人格外偏执，总担心俄国人会把阿富汗当作跳板来攻击印度。像以前有那么多人做过的那样，从开伯尔山口穿下来。因此，把阿富汗保持为一种中立的缓冲国对他们来说变得极其重要。他们对俄罗斯的影响力抱有绝对的偏执。
So the first Afghan war, which we're going to be talking to Willie Dalrymple about tomorrow, they send this mission, which goes horribly wrong and becomes the great defining debark of kind of mid-Victorian imperialism. It's this immortalized in paintings and literature and all that sort of stuff. Then the second war, now this is one that you don't often see referred to in kind of newspaper columns now because it was a success, relative success anyway. They want to basically, the Russians have penetrated through Central Asia. They've taken Bukhara. They've taken Samarkand and Kiva and all these kind of Silk Road carnates.
所以第一次阿富汗战争，我们明天将同威利·达尔林普尔谈论这个，他们派出了这次使团，结果惨败，成为维多利亚时代中期帝国主义的一个决定性耻辱。这在绘画、文学以及所有这类事物中都被永垂不朽。然后是第二次战争，现在这是一场你在现在的报纸专栏中不常看到的战争，因为它取得了成功，无论如何是相对成功。他们基本上希望，俄罗斯人已经穿透了中亚。他们拿下了布哈拉。他们拿下了撒马尔罕、希瓦和所有这些丝绸之路汗国。
And the British want to force on the Afghans a British mission. So basically, the Russians won't have the ear of the Afghan king. And the Afghans say, well, no, we don't want, we can quite happily live without British sort of diplomats in Kabul telling us what to do. So the British make, they have two goes. So in 1878, they have what seems to be a success and they install a guy called Sir Louis Cavagnari. But then he's massacred.
而英国人希望强迫阿富汗人接受一个英国使团。这样基本上俄罗斯人就不会听到阿富汗国王的心声了。阿富汗人说，好吧，不，我们不需要，没有英国外交官在喀布尔告诉我们该做什么，我们也能过得很幸福。所以英国人采取了行动，他们尝试了两次。所以在1878年，他们取得了似乎是成功的成果，并安插了一个名叫路易斯·卡瓦格纳里爵士的人。但随后他被大肆屠杀。
So they have to come back in 1880. This is where Dr. Watson is involved, Sherlock Holmes, in the 5th Northumberland Fusiliers. He's shot in either the leg or the shoulder, depending on which Conan Doyle story you read. It kind of moves about during the Holmes canon. But this is actually quite successful. So the second mission is successful.
所以他们不得不在1880年卷土重来。这就是华生医生（来自诺森伯兰燧发枪兵团第5团）参与其中的地方，也就是福尔摩斯的故事里。他的腿或肩膀中枪，这取决于你读的是柯南·道尔的哪部小说。在福尔摩斯的正典里，伤口位置总是变来变去。但这次实际上相当成功。所以第二次使团是成功的。
And in 1893, there's a thing called the Durand Line, which is the line between Afghanistan and Pakistan. I know all about this. Do you? Is it from cricket? No, it isn't. It's to do with birdwatching. That's an unexpected term.
然后在1893年，出现了一个叫做杜兰线的东西，也就是阿富汗和巴基斯坦之间的分界线。我对这个很了解。是吗？它是因板球而来的吗？不，不是的。它与观鸟有关。这是一个意料之外的词。
Yeah, it is. So the Durand Line is named after Sir Mortimer Durand. It is indeed. He was the guy who did it. And the reason that they commissioned him to do it was because he was a keen birdwatcher. And so he could combine touring the mountains with birdwatching. Well, this is a fascinating thing. You know, everyone knows about the Sykes-Picot Agreement, the end of the First World War. The legacy lingers because this divides the Pashtun people between the northwest frontier of what becomes Pakistan and Afghanistan.
是的，确实如此。所以杜兰线是以莫蒂默·杜兰爵士的名字命名的。确实如此。他就是那个划分界线的人。他们委任他做这件事的原因是因为他是一位热衷的观鸟者。因此他可以将游历群山与观鸟结合起来。嗯，这是一件令人着迷的事情。你知道的，每个人都知道第一次世界大战结束时的赛克斯-皮科协定。这种遗产挥之不去，因为它在后来成为巴基斯坦的西北边境和阿富汗之间分裂了普什图人。
And actually, that creates a lingering sore in Afghan politics. So even in the 1970s, later than 1970s, there are Afghan politicians who still want the revision of the juror online and this explains by the way this is one of the factors in pakistani intervention and influence in 1970s 1980s afghanistan yeah and it means it explains why it's impossible for afghan politics to be divorced and separated from what's going on in northern pakistan exactly exactly because the pakis because the pakistani government are always going to be intervening because they are always anxious about keeping that borderline they don't want they don't want to lose those provinces um to afghanistan and it's all the thought of samultim and durand who well from india and he retired to rock and um to rock but he retired to rock in Cornwall. Sort of David Cameron holiday destination.
实际上，这在阿富汗政治中造成了一个挥之不去的痛处。因此，甚至在20世纪70年代，比70年代还要晚的时候，仍有阿富汗政客希望修改杜兰线，这顺便解释了这也是巴基斯坦在20世纪70年代、80年代干预和影响阿富汗的因素之一。是的，这意味着它解释了为什么阿富汗政治不可能与巴基斯坦北部正在发生的事情脱节和分离。完全正确，正是因为巴基斯坦政府总是要进行干预，因为他们总是担心保持这条边界线，他们不想，他们不想把这些省份失去给阿富汗，这一切都要归功于莫蒂默·杜兰的想法，他来自印度，并在康沃尔郡的罗克退休。有点像大卫·卡梅伦的度假胜地。
Yes. And wrote books about cormorants. Right. So he lived happily ever after anyway. Classic British imperial story. So that's the second Afghan war. That's Dr. Johnson's... Dr. Johnson's...
是的。并且写了关于鸬鹚的书。好吧。无论如何，他过上了幸福快乐的生活。典型的英国帝国故事。所以那是第二次阿富汗战争。那是约翰逊医生的……约翰逊医生的……
Dr. Johnson. Can't imagine Dr. Johnson fighting in an Afghan war. That's Dr. Watson's Afghan war. And it's after that that you have the most famous, probably the single most famous thing ever written about Afghanistan, which is the man who will be king, Kipling's short story. So in that story, you have these two characters. I mean, you must know this, Tom.
约翰逊医生。无法想象约翰逊医生在阿富汗战争中战斗。那是华生医生的阿富汗战争。正是在那之后，你才有了关于阿富汗最著名、可能是有史以来关于阿富汗的最著名作品，也就是吉卜林的短篇小说《奇人》。所以在那个故事里，你有这两个角色。我的意思是，汤姆，你一定知道这个。
Pichi Karnan. It's a fabulous story. And Daniel Dravot. And off they go to Kafiristan, which, interestingly, in the story is pagan. And in reality, it was pagan. It was not yet. So Kafirs are people who are non-Muslim. Exactly.
皮奇·卡纳恩。这是一个极好的故事。还有丹尼尔·德拉沃特。他们出发去喀菲里斯坦，有趣的是，在故事中它是异教的。在现实中它也是异教的。还不是。所以喀菲尔人就是非穆斯林的人。
And there was a place called Kafiristan. It's now Nuristan. And famously, it all goes wrong. You know, and the story is often seen as this great metaphor for British imperialism. Yeah, absolutely. But that kind of creates that image, doesn't of afghanistan as lawless and as a place where adventurers can go and carve out carve out a kingdom but they'll then it'll end horribly and they'll be killed on a bridge and crucified and yeah and all the terrible things that happen to
曾经有一个地方叫喀菲里斯坦。现在它是努里斯坦。众所周知，这一切都出了问题。你知道的，这个故事经常被视为英国帝国主义的一个伟大隐喻。是的，绝对是。但这在某种程度上创造了那种形象，难道不是吗？把阿富汗视为一个无法无天的地方，一个冒险家可以去开辟一个王国的地方，但随后它会以可怕的方式结束，他们会被杀死在桥上并被钉死在十字架上，是的，以及所有发生在
the two characters michael cain and um and sure glory yeah um so then there's a third afghan war british anglo-afghan war this is one that the Afghans actually unusually start. So at the end of the First World War, I don't know why they waited until the end of the First World War. I do not know. They'd had the best part of five years when they ought to have struck and they wait until it's over and then they decide to make their move when the British are no longer distracted.
那两个角色迈克尔·凯恩和肖恩·康纳利身上的可怕事情，是的。然后是第三次阿富汗战争，英国-阿富汗战争。这是阿富汗人罕见地主动发起的战争。所以在第一次世界大战结束时，我不知道为什么他们一直等到第一次世界大战结束。我不知道。他们本有差不多五年的时间本该出击，但他们却一直等到战争结束，然后决定在英国人不再分心的时候采取行动。
And it's really a sort of internal Afghan thing. There's a leader called Amanullah Khan, and he's trying to shore up his power base. So he decides to launch a little invasion of British India. The British hit back. They use air power. It's one of the first instances of bombing of a city. So a single plane goes and bombs Kabul. Of course, there's great panic and terror among the local population. And it's a tactical British win. They fight back the invasion. But for the Afghans, it's quite a moment because they've kind of gone toe-to-toe with the British.
这实际上是阿富汗的一种内部事务。有一个领袖叫阿曼努拉·汗，他正试图巩固他的权力基础。因此他决定对英属印度发动一场小型入侵。英国人进行了反击。他们使用了空中力量。这是轰炸城市的最早实例之一。因此一架飞机去轰炸了喀布尔。当然，当地居民中存在着巨大的恐慌和恐怖。这是英国人的一次战术胜利。他们击退了入侵。但对于阿富汗人来说，这是一个相当重要的时刻，因为他们某种程度上与英国人正面交锋了。
They have asserted their independence. They forced the British to agree that they'll no longer influence Afghanistan's foreign policy, which the British had been doing in the late Victorian Edwardian period. And it sort of paves the way for – the interesting thing is that paves the way for actually what's quite a golden period for Afghanistan. So Amanullah, I mean, he's a kind of almost an Ataturk figure, isn't he? Absolutely. He wants to be –
他们宣称了自己的独立。他们迫使英国人同意不再干涉阿富汗的外交政策，而英国人在维多利亚晚期和爱德华时期一直在这样做。这为——有趣的是，这为阿富汗实际上相当辉煌的时期铺平了道路。所以阿曼努拉，我的意思是，他几乎是一个类似凯末尔式的人物，不是吗？绝对是的。他想要——
I mean, the irony is that they've banished the British, but actually he is the kind of – he wants to westernize Afghanistan. He does, exactly. banished the British, but actually he is the kind of, you know, he wants to westernize Afghanistan. And the totemic policy, which is obviously a fracture line that runs through modern Afghan history right the way up to the present day is around the emancipation of women. The veil in particular. You're absolutely right about education and the veil. And that runs right through Afghan history from Amanullah, right through the most famous exponents, I suppose. Well, one of the most famous is Mohammed Zahid Shah, who was king from 1933 to 73. He's another modernizer.
我的意思是，具有讽刺意味的是，他们赶走了英国人，但实际上他是那种——他想要将阿富汗西化。他确实如此，绝对是的。赶走了英国人，但实际上他是那种，你知道的，他想要将阿富汗西化。其标志性的政策（这显然是贯穿现代阿富汗历史直到今天的一条断层线）是关于妇女解放的。特别是面纱。你对教育和面纱的看法绝对是正确的。这贯穿了阿富汗的历史，从阿曼努拉开始，一直延续到我猜最著名的倡导者。嗯，其中最著名的是穆罕默德·查希尔·沙阿，他从1933年到1973年担任国王。他是另一个现代化主义者。
And you can see Afghanistan exactly as you say, in the context of other countries that are trying to do the same thing, that have this sort of pressure to's this pressure to modernise, to build universities, to build schools, to westernise, because Western values are seen by elites as modernity. But also the inevitable kickback. Of course. So Amanullah gets kicked out, doesn't he?
正如你所说，你可以把阿富汗放在与其他试图做同样事情的国家的背景下来看，这些国家承受着这种压力，即现代化的压力，建设大学的压力，建设学校的压力，西化的压力，因为西方价值观被精英们视为现代性。但这也伴随着不可避免的反弹。当然。所以阿曼努拉被赶下台了，不是吗？
He does indeed. There's a civil war at the end of the 1920s. And he has the first, he's the first person to be airlifted out. Yes. So the British send a plane and get him out. Exactly. So that's sort of setting up a bit of a template. But actually, you know what?
他确实被赶下台了。20世纪20年代末发生了一场内战。他是第一个被空运撤离的人。是的。所以英国人派了一架飞机把他接了出去。没错。这在某种程度上为以后树立了一个样板。但实际上，你知道吗？
Zahir Shah, who rules from 1933 to 73, he's pretty successful. So for 40 years, there is a much more gradual period of modernization. So they start to build universities. They import foreign advisors. This is the sort of heyday in the 60s of the hippie trail of Afghanistan being actually a peaceful place that you go on the way to India as a sort of sidetrack from India. In 1964, there's a constitution that has universal suffrage, that has women's rights, political parties and so on. So Afghanistan is not by any means, it's not a basket case.
查希尔·沙阿从1933年到1973年在位，他相当成功。所以在40年里，有一个更加渐进的现代化时期。所以他们开始建立大学。他们引进外国顾问。这是60年代嬉皮士小径的鼎盛时期，阿富汗实际上是一个和平的地方，你可以作为去印度的中途支线去那里。1964年，出现了一部宪法，拥有普选权、妇女权利、政党等等。因此阿富汗绝不是一个烂摊子。
It's not a kind of metaphor for violence and lawlessness in the sort of early Cold War. But as in so many places. What goes wrong? Well, the pressures grow. You have university educated elites who are pushing for greater change. You have people in the countryside who are more resistant to change, who feel they're being left behind,
在早期的冷战时期，它并不是暴力和无法无天的隐喻。但正如在许多地方一样。什么出了问题？好吧，压力越来越大。你拥有受过大学教育的精英，他们在推动更大的变革。你拥有乡村里对变革更具抵触情绪的人，他们觉得被抛在了后面，
who become anxious about what they see as corruption and so on. And so basically, in 1973, the king's cousin, who is a man called Mohammed Daoud Khan, who I think is, I would say, is a pretty disastrous figure in Afghan history, he launches a coup. So the king is away. He's gone to India for an eye operation, and he's gone to recuperate on the island of Ischia.
他们开始对他们所看到的腐败等现象感到焦虑。因此基本上，在1973年，国王的堂兄（一个名叫穆罕默德·达乌德·汗的人，我认为他是阿富汗历史上的一个相当灾难性的人物）发动了一场政变。当时国王不在。他去印度做眼部手术，并去伊斯基亚岛疗养。
Oh, Italy, yeah. Yes, and he's in Ischia, and his cousin launches this coup and sets himself up as – now, you mentioned Ataturk. Dawud undoubtedly sees himself as a kind of Ataturk. He is going to be the father of the nation. I think he has a title like father of the nation or something. And he is going to drag Afghanistan, kicking and screaming, into the light of the kind of modern age.
哦，意大利，是的。是的，他在伊斯基亚，他的堂兄发动了这场政变，把自己立为——现在，你提到了凯末尔。达乌德无疑把自己视为一种凯末尔式的人物。他要成为国父。我想他有一个类似国父之类的头衔。他将把阿富汗连拉带拽地拖进现代的光明之中。
So scrapping the veil, for example, is one of his sort of trademark policies. And there's also an element of he's previously been quite a pro-Soviet figure. So Afghanistan has always trod a balancing, sort of trod a tightrope between the USA and the USSR in this period in the Cold War. And it's said of Dowd that he liked to light his American cigarettes with Soviet matches. That's the way to balance the communist and the capitalist blocs, isn't it? But, I mean, as is often the way, when you've had one coup, well, why not have another?
因此，例如废除面纱是他标志性的政策之一。此外，他以前一直是一个相当亲苏的人物。因此，在冷战时期的这一时期，阿富汗一直在美国和苏联之间走钢丝，保持平衡。人们对达乌德的评价是，他喜欢用苏联的火柴点燃他的美国香烟。这就是平衡共产主义和资本主义集团的方法，对吧？但是，我的意思是，通常情况下，当你经历过一次政变，好吧，为什么不来第二次呢？
He only lasts five years, and then the communists, the local communists, turn against him. And then you have this incredibly confused, bizarre period where the communists, there local communist party, the PDPA, the People's Democratic Party of Afghanistan, is in charge. And it's under these fellows who are constantly plotting against each other and kind of killing each other. And the communist party itself is riven with factionalism. By this point, the monarchy has been terminated. It's gone.
他只维持了五年，然后共产主义者，当地的共产主义者，就开始反对他了。然后你经历了这段极其混乱、离奇的时期，共产主义者，他们当地的共产党，即阿富汗人民民主党（PDPA）掌权了。它是在这些不断密谋反对彼此、互相残杀的家伙的统治下运作的。共产党本身就充满了派系之争。到了这个时候，君主制已经被彻底终结了。它不复存在了。
Yeah. Zahid Shah has been kicked out in 73, and it hasn't been, Daoud wasn't king, he was the dictator. So the Communist Party itself, and this is really important, because it tees up some of what we see to this day, is divided between different groups.
是的。查希尔·沙阿在73年被赶下台，而且一直没有恢复，达乌德不是国王，他是独裁者。因此，共产党内部本身（这非常重要，因为它为我们今天看到的一些情况做了铺垫）分裂成了不同的集团。
So there are two main factions. There's one called the Kalk, which is very popular among rural Pasht pastures the kind of people now who support the taliban and the other um faction is called parjam and that's more popular among that they're urban they are tagics uzbeks and so on they're university educated so you have that tension which is right there just like this day sorry like brexit that wasn't yes yes i suppose so the guardian readers and the daily express readers is that your sort of claim your well i'm just trying to put it in it's a terrible it's a terrible comparison forget it anyway anyway
所以有两个主要的派系。有一个叫卡尔克，在乡村普什图人中非常受欢迎，就像现在支持塔利班的那种人；另一个派系叫帕尔詹，在城市居民中更受欢迎，他们是塔吉克人、乌兹别克人等等，他们受过大学教育。所以你有这种张力，它一直存在，就像今天一样……抱歉，就像脱欧一样？那不是……是的，我想是的。卫报读者和每日快报读者，这是你的那种声称吗？好吧，我只是想把它放进去，这是一个糟糕的比喻，忘了吧。不管怎样，不管怎样，
they all they all start killing each other um the leaders. So the first leader, Taraki, he is suffocated after a coup. The next guy comes in, Havizullah Amin. He's got an MA in education from Columbia University. Oh, fatal. But he's a very bad man. You'd think that makes him sort of slightly weak and weedy. Quite the opposite. He is a very brutal man.
他们都开始互相残杀，领袖们也是。所以第一位领袖塔拉基在政变后被闷死。下一个上台的是哈菲佐拉·阿明。他在哥伦比亚大学获得过教育学硕士学位。哦，致命的。但他是一个非常坏的人。你可能会认为这使他显得有点软弱无力。恰恰相反。他是一个非常残暴的人。
So he says, you know, we must really drag afghanistan into the modern age and he arrests tens of thousands of people he has a personality cult now here's a really interesting and important thing that will surprise some listeners i think the soviet union are not at all encouraging this they don't like this at all why not because they can i mean the people in the soviet union in the late 70s uh they're all aged 184 they're kind of they're kind of brezhnev gromyko kosegin they're old men and they know you know you don't rush things you don't charge in they're very actually very small c conservative and they're constantly saying to i mean don't do this is madness you know you're
所以他说，你知道，我们必须真正把阿富汗拉入现代，他逮捕了成千上万的人，他搞个人崇拜。现在这里有一个非常有趣且重要的事情，我想这会令一些听众感到惊讶，苏联人根本不鼓励这样做。他们一点也不喜欢这样。为什么不呢？因为他们可以——我的意思是，70年代末苏联的人……他们都18岁到84岁了，他们有点像勃列日涅夫、葛罗米柯、柯西金，他们是老人，他们知道，你知道的，你不能操之过急，你不能盲目冲动。实际上他们是非常小写的保守派，他们不断对……我的意思是，别这么做，这是疯狂的，你知道，你将要
going to completely upset everything you're going to provokemin, don't do it. This is madness. You know, you're going to completely upset everything. You're going to provoke a massive reaction. And do you think that, because I think it isn't, Macmillan is advising Douglas Home, don't invade Afghanistan. I mean, it's kind of, you know, it's a kind of passing message from British Prime Minister to his successor. Don't invade Afghanistan. Whatever you do, don't do it.
完全搅乱一切，你会引发巨大的反应。你认为，因为我认为不是这样，麦克米伦在建议道格拉斯·霍姆不要入侵阿富汗。我的意思是，这有点像，你知道的，这是英国首相传给其继任者的某种遗言。不要入侵阿富汗。无论你做什么，千万不要这么做。
There's surely very little chance of Charlie Douglas Home invading Afghanistan. Well, exactly. But this is obviously a kind of, you it's it's it's prime minister from prime minister don't invade afghanistan it's the same thing it's a kind of folk memory in russia you know well do not invade it but this is a complete misapprehension in the west and continues to this day that the soviet union invades afghanistan because they're kind of you know they're like hitler in the 1930. This is not the case at all. Armin is constantly saying, because his policies provoke such resistance in the Afghan countryside, and it creates a massive insurgency, and he's constantly saying to the Kremlin,
查理·道格拉斯·霍姆入侵阿富汗的可能性微乎其微。嗯，确实如此。但这显然是一种，你知道的，总理对总理说“不要入侵阿富汗”，这在俄罗斯是一种根深蒂固的集体记忆，你知道，就是“千万别入侵”。但这在西方是个彻头彻尾的误解，而且一直延续到今天，人们认为苏联入侵阿富汗是因为他们就像20世纪30年代的希特勒那样。事实根本不是这样。阿明一直在说，因为他的政策引发了阿富汗乡村地区的强烈抵抗，导致了大规模的叛乱，他不断地对克里姆林宫说：
send me loads of troops, come and help me kill all these people. And the Kremlin are constantly saying saying no we this is the last thing we want to do is get involved in afghanistan i mean at one point they but the kgb decide this guy's complete loose cannon this is 1979 this guy's complete loose cannon we'll get his chef to they get a chef to poison him but disastrously they don't tell the soviet embassy so the soviet doctors save him so he's been poisoned by the chef. So we get to the end of 1979. It's all really kind of everything's going to pot.
“快给我派大批军队来，来帮我把这些人都杀了。”而克里姆林宫则不断地回答：“不，我们……这绝对是我们最不想做的事，就是卷入阿富汗。”我的意思是，有一段时间，克格勃认为这家伙彻底失控了，那是1979年，这家伙完全是个疯子，我们要让他的厨师去……他们找了个厨师去毒死他，但极其糟糕的是，他们没有通知苏联大使馆，结果苏联医生救了他，所以他虽然被厨师下毒了却活了下来。就这样，时间来到了1979年底。一切都真的彻底乱套了。
Now, already the United States and Pakistan are funding the insurgency. So this is before a single Soviet tank has rolled across the river. And the insurgency is Islamist. Yes. So Islam is obviously part. Well, it's not islamist islam is a huge part of it and islam proves a very good way of transcending the tribal and ethnic divisions i mean that's the power of the class traditions and the class exactly so islam is what binds it binds you in opposition to the infidel invader. But as you say, really important to emphasize that the divisions are not just between
此时，美国和巴基斯坦已经在资助叛乱了。所以这甚至是在苏联坦克跨过河岸之前发生的。而且这场叛乱是伊斯兰主义的。是的。所以伊斯兰教显然是其中一部分。嗯，与其说是伊斯兰主义，不如说伊斯兰教是其中极其重要的一部分，并且伊斯兰教被证明是超越部落和种族分裂的一种绝佳方式，我的意思是，这就是阶级传统的力量，阶级……完全如此。所以伊斯兰教将人们凝聚在一起，让他们团结起来反对异教徒侵略者。但正如你所说，非常重要的一点是要强调，这种分裂并不仅仅存在于
Islam and secular modernity. It's class, ethnic, I mean, rural and urban. All those things run through Afghan history, or modern Afghan history. So you get to the end of 1979. Now, the
伊斯兰教与世俗现代性之间。还有阶级、种族，我的意思是，乡村与城市。所有这些因素都贯穿于阿富汗的历史，或者说现代阿富汗的历史。所以时间来到了1979年底。现在，
conversations the Soviet guys have are so fascinating you can read about them online and declassified documents they know it's like vietnam they absolutely know that and for a long time the red army and the kgb their analysts have been saying the last thing we should do is send troops to afghanistan this is this would be a very very bad move and again and again gromiko and kasigan who are the two kind of i mean brisnev is basically a walking corpse so they're the kind of decision makers they say no this is a very, very bad move. And again and again, Gromyko and Kosygin, who are the two kind of – I mean, Brezhnev is basically a walking corpse, so they're the kind of decision-makers. They say, no, this is a very, very bad idea. We shouldn't do it.
苏联高层之间的对话非常迷人，你可以在网上和解密文件中读到这些内容。他们知道这就像越南战争，他们心里非常清楚。很长一段时间以来，红军和克格勃的分析人士一直在说，我们最不应该做的事就是派兵去阿富汗，这将是非常非常糟糕的一步。葛罗米柯和柯西金一次又一次地——这两个人算是——我的意思是勃列日涅夫基本上是个行尸走肉，所以他们算是决策者——他们说，不，这是一个非常非常糟糕的主意。我们不应该这么做。
And the reason they do it, Tom, is because they're so alarmed by the insurgency and by Pakistani and US-funded insurgency. So it's a classic. But also the Iranian revolution has happened by now. Yeah, of course. So they're worried about Islamlam islamism coming up through afghanistan into central asia so they invade afghanistan as the least worst option and the plan is you know they don't want to conquer it and kind of sow salt on the in the
汤姆，他们这么做的原因，是因为他们对叛乱以及巴基斯坦和美国资助的叛乱感到无比惊恐。所以这是一个典型的情况。但与此同时，伊朗革命也已经爆发了。是的，当然。所以他们担心伊斯兰主义会通过阿富汗蔓延到中亚，因此他们入侵阿富汗，将其视为两害相权取其轻的无奈之举。他们的计划是，你知道，他们并不想征服这里，然后在喀布尔的废墟上撒盐，游街展示被打败的敌人的头骨。他们只想进去，杀死阿明这个显而易见的疯子，扶植一个友好的政府，然后撤出来，把这事忘得一干二净。正如我们所知，正如他们所担忧的那样——其中一些人确实担忧过——局势极其糟糕地演变成了兰博电影般的局面，或者说詹姆斯·邦德卷入了美国间谍机构和特种部队的生活中……是的，是的，这是一场可怕可怕的战争。苏联在1985年达到巅峰时，有11万驻军。这完全是越战的经典模式。
ruins of kabul and parade the skulls of their defeated enemies all they want to do is get in kill armin who's clearly a complete head case install a friendly government get out and forget all about it and as we all know as they had feared as some of them had feared it goes rambo horrendously or james bond gets involved in the living the elite of the american spy agencies and special forces yeah yeah and it's a horrible, horrible war. The Soviet Union at their peak have 110,000 troops in 1985. It's a classic Vietnam pattern.
他们控制城市。他们用直升机发动搜剿行动。但这并没有真正起作用，部分原因是我们之前讨论过的那种地形。部分原因在于，正如我们在过去20年里看到的，特别是在乡村地区，许多人极度痛恨那种听命于外国傀儡主子的腐败城市政府。你看到穆斯林志愿者从沙特阿拉伯和巴基斯坦获得资助并涌入，其中最著名的就是本·拉登。
They hold the cities. They launch search and destroy missions with helicopters. But it doesn't really work, partly because of the terrain that we've talked about. Partly because, you know, as we've seen in the last 20 years, particularly in the countryside, a lot of people just hate the thought of a corrupt urban government following the orders of its kind of foreign puppet masters. You get Muslim volunteers coming in from funded by Saudi Arabia and Pakistan, most famously Osama bin Laden.
你还有美国的介入。我的意思是，美国人在巅峰时期每年投入6亿美元。这个叫查理·威尔逊的人。查理·威尔逊的战争是由汤姆·汉克斯出资拍摄的电影。是的，所有那些后来被痛斥为美国敌人的人，当时都被奉为自由的友人。是的，绝对如此。我的意思是，有一段时间，里根还在白宫欢迎圣战者。
You get American. I mean, the Americans are putting in, at the peak, $600 million a year. This guy, Charlie Wilson. Charlie Wilson's war is paid by Tom Hanks. Yeah, and all the people who subsequently will be excoriated as the enemies of America are fated as friends of freedom. Yeah, absolutely. I mean, at one point, Reagan welcomes Mujahideen to the White House.
这些可不是塔利班。其中许多人正是后来塔利班要与之战斗的人。嗯，他们是军阀，对吧？他们是军阀。所以他们也拥有……他们很多人其实是封建式的人物。完全正确。
Now, these are not the Taliban. A lot of these people are the people the Taliban will be fighting against. Well, they're warlords, aren't they? They're warlords. So they also have... They're kind of feudal figures, a lot of them. Exactly.
他们有点像部落领袖、黑帮分子，呃……不过“军阀”这个词绝对最贴切。我的意思是，典型的人物就是杜斯塔尔元帅。是的，他大概每隔一段时间就会叛变。我的意思是，他现在还参与其中，不是吗？是的，塔利班占领了他的官邸，你知道的，还去转动那些金水龙头之类的。但我意思是，他叛变的次数太频繁了。他是个乌兹别克人，而且他反复无常。他在乌兹别克族群中非常受欢迎，但我觉得……还有在阿富汗北部。所以这里地理因素再次发挥了作用，塔利班的大本营是在南部，对吧？
They're kind of tribal leaders leaders gangsters um but i mean warlords is exactly the word i mean the classic one's marshall dustin yeah he changes sides about every i mean he's still involved now isn't he he's yes the taliban occupied his palace and you know trying the turning the gold taps and things but i mean he he has changed sides so often he's an uzbek and he has changed sides. He's very popular in the Uzbek community, but I think... And in Northern Afghanistan. So there's also the geography kicks in again, that the Taliban heartlands are in the South, right?
是的，没错，就在坎大哈周围。是的。所以俄罗斯的入侵，对所有相关人员来说简直是一场残酷的浩劫。它绝对让俄罗斯本土的局势变得不稳定，特别是对乌克兰而言，红军士兵中大约有四分之一是乌克兰人。但人员伤亡极其惨重，我的意思是，你知道，至少有一百万阿富汗人丧生，有人说两百万。实际上，就苏联而言，官方数字说大约是14000人，但实际数字可能要多得多。这真是一场可怕可怕的战争，而且结局也极其糟糕，不是吗？纳吉布拉，是的。
Yeah, exactly, around Kandahar. Yeah. So the Russian invasion, I mean, it's utterly brutalising for all involved. It definitely sort of destabilises things in Russia itself, and particularly actually in Ukraine, about one in four of the soldier the red army soldiers ukrainians but the casualties are enormous i mean you know there's at least a million afghans some say two million die um actually among the soviets the official figures say about 14 000 but it's probably much more it's just a horrible horrible war as it ends horribly doesn't it with it doesn't bula yes
尽管他坚持的时间更长一些，我必须说，最近几天网上有不少人指出这一点，苏联扶植的傀儡政权维持的时间比美国支持的政权还要长。但他最后的结局是……他最终在电线杆上被虐待并阉割了。是的，尽管他倒台了，期间有一点小小的间歇，一个有些混乱的故事。他被推翻了，但在纳吉布拉周围发生了一些事情。实际上，他做了一件很不寻常的事，汤姆。在1992年被军阀推翻后，他依然在喀布尔流连。但他随后在喀布尔把彼得·霍普克克的著作翻译成英文。
although he lasted longer i have to say i mean quite a few people have pointed this out online in in recent days the russian the soviet client regime lasts longer than the the coalition backs but he ends up he ends up being um tortured and castrated he does in a telegraph pole yeah although he falls there's a slight hiatus, a slight confusing story. He's toppled, but then he hangs around Najibullah. And he does an extraordinary thing, actually, Tom. He hangs around after he's toppled in 1992 by the warlords. But then he hangs around in Kabul translating the works of Peter Hopkirk into English.
这真是意想不到。是的。他对阿富汗历史产生了浓厚的兴趣，翻译了《大博弈》。塔利班在1996年攻入喀布尔。正如你所说，他们对其实施了肢解、折磨和阉割，这就是他的结局。所以，人们经常说塔利班是中世纪的，但这是不对的。塔利班非常现代。塔利班的兴起是对苏联战争及其混乱余波的一种反应，尤其是对军阀割据的反弹。因此他们在普什图族人中很有号召力。
That's unexpected. Yeah. He comes really interested in Afghan history, translates the great game. The Taliban pitch up in 1996. And as you say, they mutilate, torture, castrate him, and that's the end of him. So the Taliban, so people often say the Taliban are medieval, but that's not right. The Taliban are very modern. The Taliban originate in reaction to the chaos of the Soviet war and its aftermath, and in particular the warlordism. So they've got appeal among ethnic Pashtuns.
他们吸引了那些认为腐败横行、军阀胡作非为的人。他们提供基本的公共服务。其中也包含一种阶级层面的因素。是的。当然，他们也是那些奋起反抗阿富汗精英阶层的人。是的，这里面还有一种奇怪的性维度，西方媒体通常不会报道这一点，因为西方媒体的叙事几乎完全围绕着女性展开。
They appeal among people who think there's too much corruption. There's sort of depredations of the warlords. They provide basic services. There's also a kind of class element. Yeah. And of course they are the people rising up against the Afid elites. Yeah. And there's also a kind of weird sexual dimension to it that often doesn't get covered in the Western press, where the narrative is almost entirely about women.
以及在塔利班统治下女性如何被隔离。这是人所共知的，也是塔利班最臭名昭著的特征。但这也意味着男性与女性被隔离开来。因此，在阿富汗有着悠久的传统，这种女性隔离的做法可以追溯到许多许多世纪以前，那就是男性将年轻男孩带大并训练他们成为舞者。这些男孩会穿上女性的舞蹈丝绸服装，戴着铃铛等饰品。这在阿富汗文化中是被接受的一部分。但是，在那样一场极其残酷的战争中击败共产主义者的军阀们，基本上将这种传统用作他们从事鸡奸和强奸的手段。
And the way in which women are secluded under the Taliban. It's notorious. It's the thing that the Taliban are most notorious for. Because what that also means is that men are separated from women. And so there's this lengthy tradition in Afghanistan, and this kind of seclusion of women is one that goes back many, many centuries of men taking young boys and training them as dancers. And the boys kind of dress up in female dancing silks and bells and things. And this is kind of an accepted part of Afghan culture. But the warlords who defeat the communists in that incredibly brutal war, they use this tradition basically as a way to kind of engage in paedophile rape.
因此，对于大批塔利班支持者来说，他们焦虑的不是他们的女儿会发生什么，而是他们的儿子会发生什么。而毛拉·奥马尔，围绕塔利班崛起的一个奠基神话就是：他抓住了两个正在强奸男孩的男人，然后处决了他们，把他们绞死。正是这一点，点燃了道德导火索，让塔利班得以爆发。这也是美国占领阿富汗期间一直在阿富汗国内暗流涌动的不满之源——基本上，美国人一直在对他们的许多阿富汗支持者延续这一传统的行为睁一只眼闭一只眼。
And so for large numbers of Taliban supporters, the anxiety is what's going to happen not to their daughters, but to their sons. And Mullah Omar, I foundational myth around the emergence of the Taliban is that he takes two men who are raping a boy and he executes them, he hangs them. And this is what provides the lights, the moral fuse that enables the Taliban to burst. And this is something that has been a kind of rumbling source of discontent in Afghanistan throughout the period of the American occupation, is that basically the Americans have been turning a blind eye to the way in which a lot of their kind of Afghan supporters have been carrying on this tradition.
嗯，我认为对于历史学家来说，塔利班的故事是一个极其迷人的故事，因为很显然，你知道，他们能存活这么久绝非偶然。他们能挺过美国人的击败——或者说2001年表面上的失败——以及随后的长期叛乱，不仅仅是因为他们是什么超级大 villains（大反派）。他们有其吸引力。他们扎根于阿富汗南部那种普什图族的、乡村类型的大本营。但同时，他们的伊斯兰主义也允许他们吸纳其他人。比如那些被激进化的群体等等。正如你所说，我昨天读到卡内基国际和平基金会的一份非常迷人的报告。
Well, I think the story of the Taliban for a historian is a fascinating story, because clearly, you know, they haven't survived for as long as they have. They haven't survived defeat by the Americans or apparent defeat in 2001. And then all this long period of the insurgency, just because they are sort of supervillains. They have an appeal. They're rooted in that kind of southern Afghan, Pashtun, rural kind of heartland. But also their Islamism allows them to bring in other people as well. So people who've been radicalized and so on. And as you say, I mean, there's a fascinating, I read a fascinating report yesterday by the Carnegie Endowment for Peace.
那是2009年写的，非常有先见之明。作者是一位名叫吉尔·德隆-索罗的法国塔利班专家，他在报告中基本上指出：你知道，我们完全低估了塔利班。他们反对腐败，他们提供乡村公共服务。
I've written in 2009, very prescient, in which the author, who is a French specialist on the Taliban called Gilles Deron-Sorot, he basically says, you know, the Taliban, we're completely underestimating them. They're anti-corruption. They provide rural services.
他们拥有反抗异教徒侵略者的言辞。他们利用人们对城市和现代性的不信任，当然，他们还迎合了人们的那种乡村的、种族的、传统的认同感。这种号召力和影响力是联军部队自始至终都未能真正克服的。而且联军部队一直都在玩着以往殖民侵略者玩过的游戏，那就是占领城市。
They have the rhetoric of resistance to infidel invaders. They play on people's distrust of the cities and a modernity and obviously they appeal to people's kind of rural ethnic kind of traditional identity and that's something that clearly hasn't had an appeal and had a potency that the coalition um forces just never really managed to overcome. And the coalition forces were always playing the game that previous colonial invasions have played, which is to occupy the cities.
阿富汗人根本不想在正面战场上迎战现代化的西方军队。我的意思是，这种情况一直可以追溯到1842年，他们会融入乡村，然后你知道的，慢慢地扼杀城市。基本上这次也是这么发生的。当然还有所有涌入阿富汗的资金，包括援助、美国的资金等等。这造成了一种强烈的腐败感，这再次印证了塔利班自20世纪90年代以来一直在说的一切。而且这确实是真的。你知道，他们在“预防罪恶与弘扬美德部”的标语上写着一句不可思议的话：把理智抛给狗吃。
Afghans don't want to meet modern westernised armies in the field. I mean, that's true going all the way back to 1842 they melt into the countryside and then they just you know slowly throttle the cities and that's basically what's happened this time around as well and also of course all the money that flowed into you know flowed into afghanistan the aid, the American money and so on. It created a great sense of corruption, which again played into everything that the Taliban had been saying since the 1990s. And of course, it's true. You know, they have this incredible slogan on the slogan on the Ministry for Prevention of Vice and Promotion of Virtue. Throw reason to the dogs.
这散发着腐败的气息。哇。是的，非常反启蒙。是的，所以汤姆，显然我们聊得太久了，而且这只是一次匆忙的走马观花式的回顾，但我觉得如果不留下一些关于干涉主义和帝国主义的反思就结束，会显得很奇怪。那么你认为阿富汗的命运——我的意思是，这无疑是一场失败，无论如何粉饰都无法将其说成是成功的。乔·拜登一直反对继续对阿富汗进行占领和干涉，他以很早就对此持批评态度而闻名。你认为他是对的吗？你认为阿富汗政府的崩溃证明了这种干涉根本行不通吗？西方对这里的干涉……我感觉自己没有资格对此发表高见，
It stinks of corruption. Wow. Yeah. Very anti-enlightenment yes so tom obviously we've gone on far too long and uh it's been a real whistle stop tour but i think it'd be weird to end without a few reflections about intervention and imperialism so do you think the afghan the fate i mean it has been a failure there's no doubt about it i mean there's no way you can spin it as a success joe biden was always against continuing the afghan occupation and the intervention he famously was a critic of it from a very quite an early stage do you think he's right do you think he's been sort of do you think the collapse of the afghan government proves the intervention just doesn't work western intervention in this? I don't feel qualified to opine on that
因为我对阿富汗的现状了解得还不够深，无法判断是否有可能在那里建立一个稳定的政府，或者是否有可能根除那些令许多阿富汗人反感的腐败现象和其他问题。我也不知道如果美国人继续保持在那里的存在，局势是否有可能朝那些方向发展。但我毫无疑问，这是一场帝国主义的冒险。我的意思是，在我看来，这绝对是回溯到第一次阿富汗战争的连续体的一部分。从某种意义上说，
because I don't know enough about the state of Afghanistan to know whether it would have been possible for a stable government to be established for some of the corruption and the things that were offensive to many Afghans to be cured. And I don't know whether it would have been possible for those routes to go down had, you know, the Americans retained their presence there. But I have no doubt that it was an imperial venture. I mean, it seems to me absolutely part of a continuum reaching back, you know, to the first Afghan war. And in a sense, the, you know,
西方世界面临的巨大心灵创伤在于女性将会遭遇什么。正如我们所说，这在阿富汗至少已经成了一个世纪以来争论不休的焦点。这是西方化精英与田野乡间民众之间产生紧张关系的巨大避雷针。从某种意义上说，这种现实政治的融合——你知道，我们必须留在阿富汗以阻止基地组织扎根等等，以及我们必须留在阿富汗以推动女性解放事业并维护性别平等——绝对是帝国主义传统的一部分。确实如此。它是理想主义与现实政治的结合，曾是英国帝国主义的一部分，如今也依然是美国帝国主义的一部分。
the great trauma in the West is what will happen to women. And that's been a bone of contention in Afghanistan, as we've said, for at least a century. It's the kind of the great lightning rod for tension between westernized elites and people out in the fields. And in a sense, that fusion of kind of realpolitik, you know, we've got to be in Afghanistan to stop Al-Qaeda bedding down or whatever. And we've got to be in Afghanistan to promote the cause of female emancipation and to preserve gender equality. That is absolutely part of the imperial tradition. It is. It's a fusion of idealism and realpolitik that was part of British imperialism and remains today
但可以说这也是一个弱点，我会这么说。如果你既半理想主义又半现实主义，你往往会两头不讨好。我的意思是，我要说的是，要么你彻底做好它，要么就索性别去碰。正如我们之前在一期播客中讨论过的那样，美国是一个反帝国主义的帝国。是的，它是反帝国主义的帝国主义。从某种意义上说，
part of American imperialism. But it's arguably a weakness i would say um if you're half idealistic half rail policy you can sort of fall between two stools i mean what i would say um is either you do it properly or you don't do it at all and i think you know we talked before about the united state in a previous podcast the united states is an anti-imperialist empire yeah it was anti-imperialist imperialism and in a way you know had we talked before about the United States in a previous podcast, the United States is an anti-imperialist empire. Yeah. It was anti-imperialist imperialism.
如果在2001年他们进入阿富汗时说：“我们不在乎你们叫我们帝国主义者。基本上我们要在那里待50年，甚至可能永远待下去。我们要把阿富汗当作殖民地来对待，我们要以残酷的决心进行统治，无论如何。”是的，他们现在依然会待在那里。因为正如我们所说，你知道，征服阿富汗是完全可能的。
And in a way, you know, had they gone in, in 2001, and said, we don't care if you call us imperialists. Basically, we're here for 50 years, maybe here forever. We're going to treat Afghanistan as a colony, and we will rule with ruthless determination or whatever. Yeah, they'd still be there now. Well, because as we've said, you know, it's perfectly possible to conquer Afghanistan.
如果你，你知道，如果你强迫人们扛着自己家乡城市的泥土游行，然后将其与他们的血混合在一起。我的意思是，这种选项一直都是存在的。我们当时并没有打算这么做。但我确实认为，在本土，
Yeah. If you, you know, if you kind of frog march people carrying the soil of their native city and then mix it with their blood. I mean, the option is always there. We weren't going to do that. But I do think, I mean, I do think it's striking that, you know, back in the homeland,
特别是美国本土，对帝国主义的反对情绪可能比以往任何时候都更加激烈。英国也是如此。我的意思是，帝国主义已经完全变成了一个脏词。然而与此同时，是的。好吧，你可以去看某个人的推特时间线，汤姆。一条在上午8点发送的推文说：“我真的必须赶快去对这个课程进行去殖民化，并推翻一座维多利亚时代将军的雕像。”而在20分钟后发送的第二条推文却说：“我们必须
particularly the American homeland, opposition to imperialism is probably more passionate than it's ever been. And in Britain as well. I mean, imperialism has become a completely dirty word. And yet, at the same time. Yes. Well, you can go down somebody's timeline tom twitter timeline and and and tweet a sent at 8 a.m says i really really need to hurry up with decolonizing this curriculum and demolishing the statue of a victorian general and tweet b sent 20 minutes later says we've got
对阿富汗做点什么，我们必须对阿富汗采取行动，我们逃跑了真是太可耻了。”你就会想，好吧，真是够了。我的意思是，这里存在着一个明显的矛盾。我猜，我相信塔利班一定意识到了这些矛盾。我的意思是，你认为他们一直在关注课程的去殖民化吗？我觉得他们当中有些人是一些精明的发言人。没错，他们要精明得多，现在他们甚至开始玩推特了。不像唐纳德·特朗普那样。我认为他们完全有能力搞清楚华盛顿目前的士气状态。是的。我的意思是，实际上我认为其中的相似之处，你知道，
to do something about we must do something about afghanistan shameful that we've run away and you sort of think well come on yeah i mean there's a clear contradiction um here and and i suppose it's i mean i'm sure the taliban were aware of those contradictions i mean they do you think they've been following the decolonization of the curriculum i i i think that that some of them are kind of sophisticated spokesmen well they are much more who are now on twitter unlike say donald trump, you know, I think they're perfectly capable of, obviously, of working out what the state of morale is in Washington. Yeah. I mean, I actually think the parallels, you know,
必须对阿富汗采取点行动，我们必须对阿富汗做点什么，我们竟然逃跑了，这太耻辱了。你就会觉得，好吧，是的，我的意思是，这里显然存在一个矛盾，我想——我的意思是，我确信塔利班意识到了这些矛盾。我的意思是，你认为他们一直在关注课程的去殖民化吗？我认为他们当中有一些人是比较成熟的发言人，好吧，他们现在活跃在推特上，这与唐纳德·特朗普不同，你知道，我认为他们完全有能力弄清楚华盛顿的士气状况。是的。我的意思是，我实际上认为这些相似之处，你知道，
I'm so glad we did that Vietnam podcast before this because I think the parallels and the themes are uncannily similar, just as they were in the Soviet invasion. And the irony is that, you know, George W. Bush and Tony Blair said, uncannily the themes are uncannily similar and just as they were in the soviet invasion and the irony is that you know george w bush and tony blair said we have absolutely learned the lessons of the past we've definitely not repeating the mistakes of the soviet invasion and yet the soviet client state survived longer after the departure of soviet troops well i think i mean i think that that photo of the helicopter over the american embassy will appear on many, many, the cover of many, many textbooks.
我很高兴我们在这次之前做过那个关于越南的播客，因为我认为它们的相似之处和主题惊人地相似，就像在苏联入侵时一样。而讽刺的是，你知道的，乔治·W·布什和托尼·布莱尔曾说，主题惊人地相似，就像苏联入侵时一样，而讽刺的是，乔治·W·布什和托尼·布莱尔说，我们绝对吸取了过去的教训，我们绝对没有重蹈苏联入侵的覆辙，然而苏联的傀儡政权在苏联军队撤离后存活的时间甚至更长。嗯，我想，我的意思是，我认为美国大使馆上空的直升机那张照片将出现在许多许多教科书的封面上。
Yes, it will indeed. The decline of America and the decline of the West. It will indeed. Right. So that's the broad sweep. Tomorrow, we'll go deep into the most famous episode, I think, of imperial failure in Afghanistan, which is the first Anglo-Afghan
是的，确实如此。印证了美国的衰落和西方的衰落。确实如此。好吧，这就是宏观概览。明天，我们将深入探讨阿富汗帝国失败中最著名的一幕，我认为那就是第一次英阿
War. Welcome back, William Dalrymple. Tom, are you hoping for a word in edgeways this time? No, I don't think there's any point because, Willie, the story that he has to tell is such an extraordinary one, and he is so well qualified to tell it that I feel it would be presumption on my part to intrude in any way. There is one last thing i would like to say which is that on the topic of western imperial engagements and the damage that they can do um on monday and tuesday that's the 23rd and 24th i will be doing a walk i'll be walking 50 miles in 24 hours and among the causes that i'm raising money for is uh um of Yazidi refugees. Yazidi is a religious minority in northern Iraq who basically have had an absolutely terrible time of it recently and can't go back to their homes. So if you could in any way find it in yourselves to support that walk,
战争。欢迎回来，威廉·达尔林普尔。汤姆，这次你希望有机会插话吗？不，我觉得没必要，因为，威利，他要讲的故事是如此非凡，而且他又是如此胜任这个讲述工作，以至于我觉得如果我以任何方式插嘴，那就是自不量力了。我还有最后一件事想说，那就是关于西方帝国的介入及其可能造成的破坏，嗯，在周一和周二，也就是23日和24日，我将进行一次徒步，我将在24小时内步行50英里，我为其募款的原因之一是雅兹迪难民。雅兹迪是伊拉克北部的一个宗教少数群体，他们最近遭遇了极其悲惨的处境，无法返回家园。因此，如果您能以任何方式支持这次徒步活动，
the details are on my pinned tweet, which at holland underscore tom and the links are there so uh thanks thanks very much for that it's a great cause do please support the ian botham of history podcasting thanks a lot bye-bye bye-bye Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
详情在我置顶的推文中，推特账号是 holland underscore tom，链接就在那里。非常感谢，这是一个伟大的事业，请大家支持播客界的伊安·博瑟姆。非常感谢，再见，再见。感谢收听《历史的剩余部分》。想要获取独家节目、提前收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。